In December, I had a $500 gutzumer test through another practitioner that said I had no parasites.
I've been using human fed bed dissolved 220 grams, milligrams twice a day for months, however, I still have parasites.
I don't know what parasites that you're passing.
You, and I don't know what fed bed is all what parasites fed bed is all is the best for. So, um, if, you know, the, those, the gut, the parasite.
I'm not familiar with the Zuber tests. We don't use that lab, but I assume this was a stool sample test.
And the stool sample tests can miss things too. So, and your body can change. So, if, in December, you had this test, and it was negative, you could have picked up the parasite right after that, they reproduce quite quickly. So, um, that doesn't really
convince me that there's not a problem. And taking this, the fed bed is all doesn't convince me that it's going to solve every parasite problem either.
Yeah, you know, these are most of drugs out there are specific to just certain classes of parasites. Um, and that's all they really kill. That's why there are so many different medication medications for different parasites.
You might want to google the milk cleanse that got rid of my parasites. So that's interesting. Um, look at that. Thank you for that insight as well.
You know, there is a, not to be, um, oh, totally. I just want to throw it in another light of thought. There's a whole light of thought that that parasites are, um, are not necessarily always a bad thing. We always think of having parasites as a bad thing.
Um, there is, there is actually a company that you could actually buy capsules that have live parasites in them, and you take them in order to create a parasitic infection because it has been shown through
different studies that people with severe autoimmune diseases, if they're exposed to parasites can actually help calm down the autoimmune disease.
Um, so there is actually a therapy that you see parasites to your advantage in a symbionic relationship and the idea that, um, hey, parasites, um, can actually work to our advantage. I know we're all grossed out about parasites. We want to get rid of parasites.
The truth is, there's a study done a few years ago that I thought was kind of interesting that said anybody in the northern states they did the study comparing people in the United States in different areas anybody in northern states. I can't remember what they classified as northern states whether it stayed below freezing for X amount of months of the year.
So people in the northern states, they found that 35% of the people they tested and parasites, the people in the southern states, um, because the ground doesn't freeze. So there's a greater concentration of parasites.
Um, they show that 90% of the people tested at parasites.
So the idea is that just because you have a parasite doesn't necessarily mean that you have to work at getting rid of the parasite or that the parasite is causing you ill health.
Just think about that a little bit just because the person has a parasite doesn't mean that the parasite or parasites are the culprits that are causing ill health.
And I would argue and I talk about this in the autoimmune course that it is really the problem really comes in with parasites is when you've actually created antibodies to the parasites when you create antibodies to the pathogen.
That's when you have a problem. It's not the path that so much to pathogen itself, just like you go up and you get mosquito bites. Oh, I got a mosquito bite it inches for a couple minutes or a day and it's gone because I don't have antibodies to that better love the mosquito.
Then I don't have really much of a problem with it. It's when you have antibodies to that thing that it really causes health issues, just another point of view, not to be such a contrarian, but it's something to think about.